Ben Affleck has a new lady in his life
it's thrilling for me just three months
after filing for divorce from ex
Jennifer Garner the Justice League star
is back off the market he can confirm
that Ben is dating Saturday Night Live
producer Lindsay shooked a source told
et on Friday Ben and Lindsay have known
each other for years and met on SNL
while he was hosting the show vote it is
early on in the relationship but they
are very happy together
they started dating after Ben and Jen
separated it's a gift to to the work of
marriage which you gifted me with the
enormous work Ben and Jen called it
quits in June 2015 after ten years of
marriage they officially filed for
divorce back in April of 2017 the 44
year old actor and Lindsay have tried to
keep their relationship very low-key and
private well despite his budding romance
Ben is still putting his kids first our
source adds Ben and Jen are two people
who care deeply for their respective
families that dedication will continue
Reid or bus
[Music]
you